in some truly blockbuster bipartisanship
Republican and Democratic senators were
caught on a hot mic trashing Donald
Trump including saying that he's crazy
and a whole bunch of other stuff it's
rare that we see bipartisanship in
Washington DC and here we had Republican
senator Susan Collins from Maine and
Democratic senator from Rhode Island
Jack Reed talking about how clueless
Donald Trump is when it comes to
actually governing and after the
exchange of new statements Jack Reed
says and this is where we're going to
pick up the audio from the Washington
Post
Jack Reed says he believes Trump is
crazy it's a little hard to hear it's at
the beginning of the audio I'm about to
play and then Republican senator Susan
Collins responds she's worried about
Donald Trump as a result of his
perceived quote craziness again the
audio is from the Washington Post it's
kind of difficult to hear at the
beginning but the first line is Jack
Reed saying about Trump I think he's
crazy let's take a listen I don't say
that not lightly and as a kind of yet
you good guy and you know the
this thing you know you don't get it but
did you like somebody wasn't he
paralyzed do game everywhere yeah I
don't even think you also
controversially buttressed look less
relevant for us I'll mention it so
people don't think I'm deliberately
ignoring it Collins later in the
recording talks about congressman Blake
Farenthold a fellow Republican and she
talks about how he's huge and so
unattractive okay and we're not even
going to dig into that but she did
mention that the real scandal here is
how dare Republican Susan Collins speak
so politely to a Democrat I'm kidding
but what does this tell us this tells us
that as much as I disagree with
Republicans even Republicans like Susan
Collins who's more moderate on many
issues they aren't all [ __ ] then at
least some of them do see what's going
on here they see the scope and the
nature of what is going on with Donald
Trump that we've got a totally unhinged
unbalanced president in charge
I wish Republicans were willing to talk
this way publicly you know what I mean
Pat because then we would actually see
hey you know what even Republicans in
the House and Senate realize how bonkers
this guy is and it's not as if these
senators are saying this in front of a
campaign rally or anything else it's not
were just a public statement where
you're trying to get sound bites out of
it definitely they thought this was a
private conversation and this shows that
this is how they really feel about the
president that's right it shows that in
private
Republicans probably lack any confidence
whatsoever in Trump which is maybe a
good thing if they've already lost
confidence if Donald Trump's approval
rating continues to trickle down these
Republicans are way more likely to
publicly bail on Trump than we might
have otherwise assumed people want to
change right and they got change but
it's a type of change that no one seems
to really have much confidence in I mean
Democrats obviously have no confidence
in Trump we're learning that at least
some Republicans have no confidence in
Trump many in Trump's own staff lack
confidence in Trump given the constant
stream of leaks from his own staff as
well as the resignations just a side
note I
looked up how foxnews was reporting
about this leaked audio and when I
looked at it it omitted everything about
Trump that Collins and Reid said it was
only reporting on Collins's comments
about congressman Farenthold being
overweight and ugly I don't know if
that's been updated since but you got a
completely sanitized version of the
truth on Fox News I thought it was
perfectly fine for Collins to say what
she said especially because Farenthold
said that if she was a man he would
challenge her to a duel when I was here
a chauvinistic remark I guess you'd say
Aaron Burr style even it was very
strange everything about it was weird
and it I just don't even feel like this
Farenthold guy deserves our attention
you know that that's more my thing but
yeah colorful comments nonetheless
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t we will take a break
William Gardner joins me next
I predict a very interesting interview
today's program is made possible by taga
dabbe the hosting specialists offering a
range of flexible hosting packages
including dedicated VPS and cloud server
options as well as custom server
solutions and uk-based colocation
services for your business or project
taga DAV's web hosting services support
a wide range of customers and businesses
worldwide including bloggers tech
startups financial traders gamers web
developers and more and tag adapt has a
really user-friendly interface so you
don't have to worry about being super
tech savvy they can automate almost
everything you need for total ease of
use they are really proud of their team
of expert hosting specialists who are
also their support team 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is currently offering our
viewers and listeners a 20 british pound
free credit about 24 US dollars to all
customers signing up to give you a
chance to try the service this is a
limited availability offer first-come
first-served
for viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show to take advantage of it go
to sign up CAG adapt calm /t DPS and use
the offer code TDPS 20 all one word all
lowercase
during account registration